We need to add the logic for
the rock paper scissors game,
the logic that defines who wins.
For this, we'll need if statements.
The general form for an if statement in
Objective-C looks something like this.
It looks a lot like an if
statement in Swift,
except you always have to have
parentheses around the condition.
And of course, the statements
are followed by semi-colons.
Let's add an if statement to the defeats
method you began defining earlier in
the RPSTurn class.
We need to return true every time
the move associated with self,
the object calling this method,
defeats the opponent's move.
The opponent is being passed in here.
So we need to return true for
three cases.
If self.move is paper, and
opponent.move is rock, then return true.
Self defeats opponent.
Here's the second case.
If self.move is scissors and
opponent.move is paper then return true.
Self defeats opponent again.
You can see that the logical operators,
the equals operator, the and and
or operators,
are all the same as in Swift.
And finally if self.move is rock and
opponent.move is scissors,
return true as well.
For all other cases,
the opponent will defeat self so
the method should return false.
This method returns false if
the game is a tie, but that's okay.
We're going to handle ties
in a different method.